we can't stray far from the lights  so while I wait for another update I'm  going to catch up with the Cubs  mum is moving them so their scent  doesn't build up in one place  he doesn't want enemies like hyenas  finding them  and she may have bought them here in her  mouth but now they look eager to explore  on their own  it looks like fun but all this play  makes them way way stronger  they're from a family of very ambitious  Hunters so it's useful training too  mum has brought them all the way down to  the river so that is great news for us  so that's Prime buffalo hunting area  the fact that she's brought the Cubs  here means this is going to be the  bride's new base  Epic Adventures with Bertie Gregory a  Disney plus day Premiere September 8th  on Disney Plus